hello there guys the bad batch series
just released a trailer and
it looks incredible the art style is the
same as the clone wars season seven and
looks absolutely beautiful
the many cool things that i picked up on
in the trailer and i'll get into that
right now
so at the start of the trailer we see
the bad batch entering and landing on
kimino
looking better than ever with the
updated animation
in what looks to be the interior of
kamino we see the bad batch
fighting some clone troopers in some
other shots throughout the trailer we
also see some more combat with the clone
troopers as well
i think this confirms the bad batch
won't be affected by order 66 and
they'll have to fight their way to
survive
as they struggle to stay afloat and find
new purpose
palpatine's speech from the range of the
set is also featured in the trailer
which means we'll be seeing a new angle
from the rent of episode 3 which is
pretty damn exciting
ok so while we're on the topic of
familiar things we've seen before
this trailer shows a wrecked fan of the
star destroyer
an intense moment with a sarlacc pit and
a petorian which you can
briefly see in the background and the
return of a zaigerian slave using a
light whip
which we have previously seen in the
clone wars tv show
we also get to see the return of some
familiar faces
such as tarkin and fennec from the
mandalorian
guys i seriously love how they connected
the whole
star wars universe together and
continued to showcase the return of
familiar planets characters and settings
while still bringing something new to
the table to keep everything fresh
and exciting i'll be linking this
trailer in the description so you guys
can watch it for yourself and pick up on
other things that they have showcased
because guys this show looks fantastic
and i'm really excited for it so i
definitely recommend checking that out
now to the story of the show what we
know so far is that the series follows
the elite and experimental clones of the
bad batch as they find their way
in a rapidly changing galaxy in an
immediate aftermath of the clone war
members of the bad batch a unique squad
of clones who vary genetically from
their brothers in the clone army
each possesses a singular exceptional
skill
which makes them extraordinarily
effective soldiers and
a formidable crew in the post-clone war
era they will take
on daring merc scenario missions as they
struggle to stay afloat and find new
purpose
the animator series the bad match will
arrive exclusively on disney plus
so there you have it guys this is
everything we know about the show and
the new trailer that i've released
shows even more information so i
recommend you guys check that out
because it looks absolutely
brilliant guys the animation style is
looking better than ever like the clone
wars season 7.
um i'm really excited for this show i
believe it releases next year um but
anyway guys tell me what you think are
you excited for the bad batch
and what do you want to see in this show
tell me in the comment section below and
make sure if you haven't already to
subscribe and to hit that like button
i'll catch you guys
in the next video
[Music]
[Music]
you